We just come out of our Christmas and new year's I guess.
Break. Yeah, because it didn't really feel like.
No, no, it's never really a Christmas holiday for YouTube,
because I feel like we we've talked about this many times before,
but we'd never, we are very bad at taking breaks. If anything,
it's like the last minute.
Grind. Right. We do at the end of the year.
I mean, I've just been watching a ton of anime because it's the end of the year.
This is like my one time with a year where I actually just sit down and just
catch up to the year.
Cause you don't feel bad. Right.
Because you know that everyone's not like doing anything
bad for like just binge in a few shots. Right? Exactly. What did you binge on?
What did you watch?
Most of everything I missed in 2020.
So I watched a [inaudible]. It was so good if you watch that yet. No.
Oh, it's so good. And I don't want you to get away.
Have you met them longer? At least really good.
Like I was going into it thinking like we just got to get like a F like every
year there's everyone's like, dude, this is the, and it's going to replace that.
That's what I've just been hearing that. Yeah.
They said that about Dr. Star.
And they said that about a lot of shows last couple of years. And I'm just like,
yeah.
Did you say Carson is where I've actually got like a chop watching it?
Like I'm actually, yeah. I'm actually like hyped, like see where it goes.
It's a show that is just, it just knows what he's doing.
And it's obviously been influenced from previous Shonan, but my God,
it's just doing everything that it needs to do. Right.
All I've heard is that if you watch the anime,
it basically does everything the manga does.
So it just makes the Monga obsolete. Great. Yeah. I mean, that was just,
that was just demon Slayer, right?
Yeah. Yeah. I want, I want no Mongo get rid of Mongo.
I'm sick and tired of these.
I was like this man's done like entire monger reading streams before.
I'm about ready to throw hands right now. Exactly. Monga readers,
constantly playing the same card. Right? What is that called? Going to get old.
How many times can you use the, I've read the Monga. Oh, I use it all the. Yeah.
How many times can you use it before? You're just an. I just don't care.
I think a lot of margaritas just don't care. I mean it,
so everyone just says the jujitsu Kyson animators. Exactly.
The enemy does everything the Monga does, but betel yeah. I mean,
from what I understand, that's just a lot of [inaudible].
The way to go there. I mean, demon Slade.
Did it, you know, and the Taiwan times doing it. Yeah.
Like I don't understand why there was even a thing of, let's just,
let's just change the story unless that, you know, haven't been adapted yet.
Right? Like it hadn't been sorry, finished yet. Sorry. Um, why,
why even changed the story in my mind? Whenever everyone love this thing.
So everyone's like, yeah, everyone loves this show. Let's just change it.
I mean,
I feel like you've started watching anime after the period where there was like
so many animate adaptations that just around with the Monga and the story
that you forgotten that this was a legitimate,
like selling points where we had a Monga that followed.
I mean, we had an animal. I understand why they did it.
I'm pretty like I'm in the nineties or eighties where the nineties shun and jump
of patient's right. Where it's just like.
Oh no, I like this Mongo.
Imagine the producers were just like, I'm sick and tired of these Monga.
Rita's on their high horse. You know what? I'm a them over and make a song.
They can't say, Oh, I know what happens. That's probably why,
because they probably like brought the Monga readers to the screenings.
They were like, yeah. You know, what's going to, you know.
No, if anything, it made the Munger read a little better.
Cause then the animate watches would be like, well,
I've heard from the margarita is that this enemy is pretty good.
And then they go and they're like.
So what happens in the Mongo? Okay. Could you, could you tell us,
could you tell us, we really want to.
We're interested now finally paradise. No, but do,
do you find that like the older you get the less animated,
like the less animated that you watch,
but the more manga that you read right now?
I feel like that's like the path of every animal.
Maybe I'm not old enough yet. I don't know. I haven't got that yet.
Let me go. Like what? So like it's 25.
It was around your age.
Like monk is a thing really? Yeah. At 24. Yeah.
Well she didn't start reading manga properly. Like.
Pretty much all my life.
But the thing is like up on toll around like a couple of years ago,
I would be like very heavily, like, I'd say like 80, 20 enemy Mongo,
but now it's like kind of flipped around. I'm like 80, 20 Munga to animated.
Because you just realize that reading Monga is basically watching anime,
but just more optimized. It's basically the speed.
One version of watching anime. Right? So voice acting,
no music do this myself. Like the only,
the only pod where it could like potentially up is like on the author. Right.
There's like no second hand. It's just like pure story. Right. You know,
you don't need, you don't need anything else, but just the pure story.
And sometimes there's only one person to blame if it sucks because it's like,
you don't.
No what you're missing out because you never think about it.
Like you would never I'll keep coming back to it.
You don't know that you need a Jordan or steam in your life until you had
Giordano's theme in your life. Right.
Like part five was amazing without Jordan as theme.
But they'll pop off. Has Jordanaires 10 times you read the manga.
And I think the animal is better. Yeah.
Yeah. No, no. We can agree with, is that okay? We all agree with that.
I was like, wait, I was giving it a second to sit there. I'm like, all right,
I'm waiting for the fans. Like I like Joe Joe's by the way,
I haven't seen all the pot five yet,
but the little that I have seen is like already better than the Maga,
but not to say, but that's not to say that.
This is a very rare case where I feel like a legendary Monga has been adapted
into a legendary animation and we don't get many of those.
I think it's always one or the other.